ouvert depuis fin décembre le but de cet
accueil nouvelle génération et de
simplifier les démarches du public et
d'améliorer leur accueil
si on n'accompagne pas les outils ne
seront pas utilisées donc en fait c'est
le pari qu'on a fait c'est de mettre les
outils à disposition et de former nos
techniciens d'accueil aux techniques
d'accompagnement et d'ailleurs ça marche
puisque en 2014 nous avions un petit peu
moins de 40 % des assurés yvelinois qui
avaient un compte ameli est aujourd'hui
fin 2016 on a plus de 66 % des assurés
qui ont un compte ameli et depuis qu'on
a mis en place le nouvel accueil mais
qu'on accompagne nos assurés sur les
outils on voit bien qu'il ya une montée
en charge très forte du compte ameli il
ya l'accompagnement qui permet de
fluidifier le passage du public mais
aussi de nombreuses bornes mises à
disposition avec de nombreux services
ces bornes nous permettent de gagner du
temps en mettant à jour les cartes
vitale en imprimant les attestations de
droit en commandant des cartes
européennes en consultant les relevés de
remboursement et en imprimant des
attestations de paiement d'indemnités
journalières
elles sont disponibles pour alors pour
tous nos clients et tout au long de la
journée
tous ces outils permettent aux agents de
la cpam de se concentrer sur les
rendez-vous avec le public
le délai d'attenté est aujourd'hui de 48
heures